نجاحات متواصله تحققها جمعيه البنك
السعودي للطعام اطعام منذ تاسيسها قبل
اكثر من عشر سنوات السوبر ماركت السحابي
اخر هذه الانجازات اطعام اكسبرس مشروع
جديد تطلقه جمعيه اطعام في السعوديه والذي
يعتبر اول سوبر ماركت سحابي وغير ربحي عبر
سلسله فروع لتطويره خدمات الدعم الغذائي
وتوفير منافذ التوزيع السحابيه لفروع
اطعام
من خلال هذا السوبر ماركت يستطيع المستفيد
ان يحصل على الغذاء عن طريق الاون لاين
ايضا المتبرع ستكون لديه القدره على
اختيار المنتجات الغذائيه التي يريد
اعطائها للمستفيدين عبر تطبيق الكتروني
سيبدا العمل به قريبا اليوم وصلنا مرحله
انه بالشغل الاحترافي
حددنا عملائنا سوينا الخارطه الحراريه
واطلقناها اليوم اليوم عندنا حوالي 11 الف
عامين في المملكه كلها اليوم اطلقنا
السوبر ماركت السحابي اللي هو العميل يدخل
ويختار اول كنا نوديه له السله اليوم
بالمستقبل حيصير هو اللي يختار سلته اطعام
اكسبرس عباره عن سلسله فروع لاول سوبر
ماركت سحابي غير ربحي سوف يقام في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وهو الاول من نوع
المستوى المنطقه البدايه سوف تكون من
المنطقه الشرقيه مشيئه الله تعالى ثم سوف
ينتقل الى مناطق المملكه سوف يقدم خدمات
التسوق الغذائي المجاني للاسر المستفيده
من خلال
اكواد خاصه بالاسر
بامكانهم التسوق والتبضع في المواد
الغذائيه والحصول على الدعم اللازم بدلا
من السلاله الغذائيه وطريقه التقليديه
التي يتم العمل فيها حاليا
البنك السعودي للطعام استطاع خلال العام
الماضي من تحقيق مؤشرات ايجابيه ابرزها
توزيع اكثر من 33 الف سله غذائيه والوصول
الى 66 الف شخص للاستفاده من خدمات البنك
بالاضافه الى 500
وسبعين اسره تم التامين الغذائي عليها
طوال العام الماضي في صباح العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي مدينه الخبر